the the choice of music that I'm going
to play you
completely unwarranted music that I
think is appropriate for every occasion
is bah and bath is one of those
composers that speaks to us on such a
universal basic truth that it's
appropriate for every every occasion it
can be a funeral or a wedding it's so
interesting how you know that that the
same music can be played at both you
wouldn't you and as much as I love
Tchaikovsky and the romantic romantic
you know those are much more specific
story-driven and different kind of
emotions that you certainly wouldn't
feel appropriate playing Romeo and
Juliet at someone's funeral so Bach is
something from above above what may be
Shakespeare's funeral I don't know but
but yeah it's so Bach would be a choice
for pretty much every occasion anyway
anyone that I want to introduce even to
someone who doesn't know music I think
ba would they could connect with it on
some level and you can never go wrong
well I'm going to play for you as I
mentioned the Box choke on it's probably
one of the most famous pieces written
for the instrument many of you who are
enjoy classical music will know the
piece but it's it's I won't lecture
about it but just a just a few words
about it it's it's a it's an astounding
piece that fascinated composers all the
composers that lived after back from
Mendelssohn to Schumann Brahms they they
were all fascinated particularly with
this chacón which is part of a suite
written for the violin solo violin it's
a suite of five movements partita and
but it's force for very short movements
and then all of a sudden the end of this
partita is this huge Chaconne which is
longer than the other four movements
combined it's sort of
one wonders why he did this the
proportions were so unusual
he wrote this supposedly right after his
wife died but it's not a lament in the
as I said before you know music abbath
could be played at a funeral or a
wedding if this is not music that that
puts hard on its sleeve and laments his
wife's passing this is something much
more spiritual and I think more special
the shikon what a shikon means it's a
kind of a dance that's in three a broke
dance but it's it's a device actually
that takes a small musical figure it's
actually a series of chords just a few
chords and in this case is four bars of
music and then neat and then the
composer then does variations on these
four bars so it's it's sort of like a
theme and variations but instead of a
theme it's just a chord progression and
this allows incredible amount of
creativity what you can do with just
four chords baath takes over the course
of it's about thirteen or fourteen
minutes it's quite a long piece in fact
one of the longest single movements ever
written at that time but he takes us
just through variation sixty-four
variations on a very simple thing he
takes us through an entire range of
human emotion from tragedy loss
redemption spirituality all these things
and and and it's really an incredible
piece it's in three it's in three parts
you can kind of keep an ear open for it
sort of three segments that that go
right into each other but you can notice
them the middle one is in a major key
and this is sort of this eye
see that as sort of a glimpse of God the
sunshine sort of coming through
it goes from D minor to D major and this
is the middle section when you get to
that point you're halfway through and
then
has this major section and then it goes
back to D minor at the end and I won't
say anymore about it but it's it's it's
it's the most revered he's also very
difficult piece and particularly
difficult to play after talking for an
hour